now we run into an interesting concept
is that we'd like to have our robots
move around the screen which presents a
problem currently our canvas coordinates
are the same as our map coordinates such
that tiles zeros are on the map renders
to location zero zero on the canvas but
as a robot moves around we want them to
say at the center of the screen and the
background move around accordingly in
order to properly translate the canvas
we have to separate those two coordinate
systems such that we can map the
translated world value to the canvas
coordinates to accurately draw your goal
if you choose to accept it is to write a
function that will translate the map to
center around a given XY pair for
instance if we call center at zero zero
then the top-left corner of the map zero
zero should render at the center of the
canvas Center at 256 by 256 should put
the map coordinates of 256 256 in the
world space at the center of the canvas
now write a function that will translate
the map to center around and give an XY
pair for instance if we call centre at
zero zero in the top-left corner of the
map zero zero should render at the
centre of the canvas Center at 256 by
256 should do the corollary thing
placing coordinates of 256 256 in world
space at the centre of the canvas now
notice you'll actually need to know the
candidates within canvas height while
computing this data so you know where is
the centre of the canvas